foreign  [Music]  with nothing more than piercing look  with enough patience  a suspect will often  irrigate himself  [Music]  detective Landor one of our Cadets  hanged himself last night  that's the matter for the corner I'm  afraid that's not the end of it it's  hard  was carved from his chest  what type of fella could do this you  have to be a bad man easy to decipher  this  rumor has it  their instructions  for immortality someone there  another Cadet is missing oh I need you  to discreetly infiltrate the context  what is this Blood Simple rituals oh my  Lord man will do most anything to cheat  death  where are the facts where are the simple  facts the truth  I believe the dead haunt us because we  love them to listen  we are not close to finding who's  responsible for this than we were a  month ago  [Music]  we are closer  [Applause]  it's only a matter of time